jedi cannot help what they are
their compassion
leaves a trail you're watching et
canada's nerd alert i'm carlos
bustamante they say the news never
sleeps and that's especially true for us
fans hungry for updates on our favorite
tv and movie franchises so let's take a
look at our top stories so far this
month
the jedi code is like an itch
we cannot help it
when duel of the fates hit in the first
revealed trailer for the highly
anticipated disney plus series obi-wan
kenobi star wars fans all over the world
got goosebumps premiering this past
wednesday the teaser gives us a glimpse
of a galaxy overrun with inquisitors in
the jedi legend obi-wan kenobi in hiding
the series marks the return of many star
wars favorites perhaps most notably
hayden christensen as lord vader himself
who promises a very powerful vader in
the series i mean is there any other
kind
i do it i become the enemy
it doesn't seem fair the trailers for
doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness have given us endless amount of
water for fan theories and speculation
another big rumor is that one of the
scarlet witch's multiversal variants
will be played by one of her real life
sisters ashley olsen tweeted by
notorious marvel's spoiler slash inside
guy harry bowles this is possibly just
an idea that has captured our collective
imagination but it's a cool one
nonetheless very excited to see the
scene where this variant turns to a
stunned wanda and says
you got it dude you got it dude
the batman currently sits at 84 on
rotten tomatoes putting it in fourth
place among all of the caped crusaders
big screen appearances regardless of
what the critics would eventually think
warner brothers was confident enough in
director matt reeve's vision of gotham
to announce a couple of spin-off series
well before the movie even hit theaters
a prequel series announced back in 2020
that centered on the gotham police
department in a series starting colin
farrell's penguin that was announced
just last year well bat fans i've got
good news and bad news sorry
bad news the bad news is that the gotham
pd series has been axed with matt reeves
himself saying it's currently no longer
happening the good news is that we're
going to see a whole lot more of oz
cobblepot as hbo max has officially
ordered the penguin to series
[Music]
i can't tell the difference
between my week in life
and dreams and finally the first few
days of march have given us a deluge of
new info about moon knight to obsess
over first we have three new posters
each spotlighting one of mark spector's
personalities there's oscar isaac's mark
or maybe another unmasked personality
and stephen grant there's the fist of
conscious himself moon knight and
finally there's mr knight the more
grounded and civilized version of moon
knight that's more detective than
vigilante now on top of that this week
we also got a featurette with some
familiar footage mixed in with the
show's stars talking about what we can
expect when we finally meet the many
faces of moon night on march 30.
every aspect of this show
has a duality and we've shifted the
paradigm
for me what's really exciting is that
it's totally unpredictable of course
there are plenty more stories coming at
us all the time what nerdy movie and tv
news has you excited let's talk about it
in the comments below i'm carlos
busamante i'll see you next time
you